[Music]
version 5.3 of the firebase web SDK came
out a couple weeks ago and it includes a
cool new feature to query documents
based on an array value this means you
can get all of the documents that have
an array filled that contain a certain
value in that array this video is going
to be a lot shorter than most the
content you'll find on my channel but if
you like this format please leave me a
comment below because I'm considering
adding a couple extra videos to the
channel per week that are just a couple
minutes long that cover really focused
topics like this one here alright so
let's just go ahead and jump right into
the code I'm here in an empty directory
and I have firebase tools installed and
I'll initialize a new project by running
firebase in it and then we'll set up
fire store as well as hosting and if you
already have a firebase project you can
just skip this step completely but make
sure you have version 5.3 or greater of
the SDK installed at this point I can
just run firebase serve in my project
and we should get this initial splash
page the next thing I'll do is take out
the default JavaScript that's provided
by firebase and we'll just replace this
with our own app.js file now that we
have our web app setup we can start
writing the actual code the first thing
we want to do is make a reference to
firestorm then we also need to update
our fire store settings to avoid an
error in the console which is just
setting the timestamps and snapshots to
true then I have some existing data in
my database which is in the carts
collection you can imagine this as a
shopping cart in an e-commerce
application but let's jump to the
firebase console to see what it looks
like each cart has an items field which
is an array of different string values
so right now you can see that carts a
and B both have bananas in them let's go
ahead and add a third cart that also
contains bananas but some additional
values as well and our goal is to be
able to query these documents based on
the shared values in this items array to
handle this we can actually just use the
where clause but it now has an
additional operator that we can use
specifically for arrays so we'll say
collection where the items array array
contains whatever value we want to
search
so this is different than the normal
conditional operators that you might use
such as equals or greater than or equal
to a caveat with this method is that you
can only use at once it's not currently
possible to chain together multiple
array contains clauses and a single
query the final step is to get the data
from this query and then we'll go ahead
and map that promise down to the actual
raw data as well as the document ID for
each document that's returned in the
query we'll go ahead and just
console.log it to the browser with that
done let's go into the browser and make
sure that this actually works the
lacroix value is currently only
contained in cart a in cart C so we
should only get those two documents back
when we run the query you can see that
that's exactly what we get back in the
browser console if we change the value
to bananas we should get all three
documents back and as expected that's
exactly what happens overall this is a
really nice feature to have because in
the past what I found myself doing is
mapping arrays to an object just so I
could query them in firestorm
but this array contains operator should
eliminate the need to do that in most
cases I'm gonna go ahead and wrap things
up there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and if you want to
see more short videos like this don't
forget to leave me a comment thanks for
watching and I'll talk to you soon